[音楽]
聞くんじゃ
ドクター
[拍手]
hba
大阪で線というわけで子どもたちのみんな久しぶりなんだジム中金10ちょうだい度も
行ってますでしょうか
10禁家といっても様々の僕があります僕は確か小学生のように何をしたかというと
カップラーメンの容器で ufo をつくりまして
授業植えられと思うんですけどまあやはり王道な中研究といえばそう
スライム私ドクタージョブ何を言おうともこの youtube かにスライムを
持ち込んだ伝説の男つなげば本当に簡単に作れます選択法と o さんこの二つがあれ
ば基本的にすれば作れますた今日やるのは自由研究
普通に債務を作るではモテませんドクター
はじめの自由言及僕は夏休みにこんな細胞を作ってみると思います
ていた
待って
貼って
自動でもおれへんの
う
うん
南来でので待ってますやんだけどわー
はいです
あなりというわけだドクター白面のず有権者ニュファイターギロまで行きたいで
スライムをつくっていると思います幸い今回上の方にいい感じの被験体がいるので
ギュンの出るスライムをつくって彼らに書かせてみようと思います果たして
議論の出る液体ぱスライム鑑定すると下郎ので立ライムが作れるかどうか子
消してみようと思いますぜひともやっぱり早速つっていきましょう
用意するもの author 約5g 選択の200 c 4下呂のでできた100個
逗子市
4日
ちょっと上げてみましょう
ここに2つ目の金中にあるので中で一体をなるべく月に入りたいん
[音楽]
冗談きついよこれなニオイの種類が変化してますねー
see
ゲームでちゃったぜマネーお見苦しいシーンだと思ってるが許してくださいねー
ん
くら早速妻も作っていきましょうなぜはポップ逃げろ飲んでに行きたいと線らが納涼
同じようを入れます
[音楽]
持っていた
理由れます
ん
病衣おかー
いやーでも決して好物ではないのでご安心くださいあの日常の生活の中で進化し続けて
生まれてしまった
いきたいでございます化学物質です決して動物ではございませんご了承下さいますで
これと同じを選択取り入れてみます象聞いた
入れます
[音楽]
持っていた
goo
で混ぜていきます
まだ割とイケてる
急に車でもう頭のコップに議論できた入れます
ん
完成形こぼして終わった時点でこっちに方竿に入れます台に5g 程度入れましょう
ok で方さえだとマジます
ok すっ
えええほとん立つを混ぜたら完成ですかーっ
[音楽]
何
ん
なんか思ったよりそれっぽいものができました
ちょっとできてんじゃないこれ
ここがだけでうん
グレー
窓もにっつライムを作れるぜ人気で完売しましたこちら
ゲロ道でいきたいで付け足せライブビューロード出るスライムですまあちょっとうまく
できたらどうかわかんないんですけど明らかにおかしいな滑稽みたいなことになってき
ましたねこれでちょっと辛い無難だと思いますが医学生そんなないにしろちゃんと光景
になってるんであとちょっと伸びますね
一応せないのでございますに良いのを変えてくると思う
おります
ん
う
ちょっとでます
はいというわけで無事牛の出るスライム管理者ので早速上の日減退に本当にこれが効く
かどうか十ペースで車
エアー検証開始ですね
なりましょう
同0
いやもう入ってるー
[音楽]
ザンッ
はーい
ブルー a 1
はぁっいやー過ぎるん
あああああん
あっひっ
にゃああああ
moon ねぇこれ
醍醐際に出る
book a war ぜええええっ
me
dea
car
uh
ガスに使った議論でいきたいのすライブバージョンですよまいやだよねこれにて我
これでも議論でれ機体は収縮したんでもおっこれで終わりました
最終章でございました
俺だけ me
キャップいろいろ a